[Music]
all right there's no how-to show on TV
streaming or otherwise in Luke Cage
which we talked about a couple weeks ago
with Luke Cage himself Mike Colter in
studio it's an incredible cast my
Hershel ollie was on in season 1 rosario
Dawson alfre woodard I mean great
Castiel Rossi but only one member of the
cast however dare I say has more than
10,000 yard career rushing yards in the
National Football League 12 years in the
National Football League an all-american
in college as well good to see you
Thomas Jones how are you great to see
you to me okay I'm good it's been a
while yeah it's been a minute as they
said it's been a minute so yeah cuz the
NFL Network started in 2003 you had just
left the Cardinals your first team to
join the box you have strayed then you
join the the Bears and things really
took off for you there Chicago moving
right yeah yeah things started moving in
Chicago I mean I was drafted in 2000 by
the Cardinals first-round pick went to
Arizona you know I had a little bit of a
tough time there went through some
growing pains and in Jon Gruden traded
for me and I went to Tampa right after
they won the Super Bowl what was that
like going in there after that winning
the Super Bowl it was it was it was
incredible you know I went from like one
of the worst experiences to the best
experience possible and also got a
chance to play with Ronde Barber Michael
Pittman again so it was an incredible
experience I mean the fans I mean I
think that was what I thought the NFL
experience was and unfortunately I'm at
the time in Arizona they didn't have the
same management wasn't the same type of
situation you know we didn't have our
own stadium it was 130 degrees outside
it was it just wasn't what I expected
the NFL experience to be and a lot of
that had to do with with me as well you
know I wasn't as mature you know I
didn't put as much time in the film room
and in the weight room so it was kind of
it was a mixture of things but Tampa was
that was what I would have loved to have
had when I first came to the league
right and then you left there to go to
Chicago yeah every free agent is that
what happened I was a free agent went to
Chicago I wanted to stay in Tampa but
the deal wasn't right they ended up
bringing Charlie garner in and give him
the deal that I wanted so I was very
excited to go to
I mean guru Garner was Gruden sky right
it was funny because John wanted me to
stay it was they brought the general
manager from the Raiders okay that next
year and so he wanted to bring his guys
with him so you know Jon Gruden I'm
forever grateful to him for trading for
me and and we had an incredible
relationship in Tampa he believed in me
believed in my ability I mean every time
I would see him afterwards whether it
was Monday Night Football or wherever we
just had this connection no he brought
me into his office and he said you know
I traded for you because I believe in
you I believe in your ability and he
said I want you to watch something hit
play and it was all my college
highlights and he said do you know this
guy and I said yeah and he played
another holiday said do you know this
guy I said yeah play another I like do
you know this guy said yeah he said this
is the guy that's rated for and then he
gave me number six he said you're gonna
wear this jersey during training camp
because this is the guy's rated for
number six which was my college jersey
and so from that point on you know he
just believed in my career over the last
couple of weeks in the season he let me
start it's funny because we played our
New Orleans at New Orleans and in the
team meeting the night before he said
Thomas Jones you're gonna start this
game and the first four plays of the
game we're gonna give you the ball it
doesn't matter where we are
doesn't matter what down in distance the
first four plays so if we're backed up
if it's fourth down yeah you're getting
the ball we could be on their own 5-yard
line so we I think we got the balls
first a second and the night before I'm
in my hotel room like you know like oh
my nose it was like this is my moment
because if I don't get this first down
then you know I'll let the team down
I'll let the coaching staff down and I
didn't take advantage of my opportunity
so what's crazy is the date that the day
for the game I listened to Eminem lose
yourself before the game and and I
remember the first play I think I got
three yards then we were like on our own
five-yard line of something like say you
were back yeah we were backed up well
like I don't like we were I think
something happened with a kickoff
somebody dropped it or something huh and
it ended up being like third down and
five and we were on our own like ten
mm-hmm and so you know I'm thinking I
can't I have to get the first job I have
to get the first you and I ended up
getting seven yards so I got the first
down nice it was like the pressure was
all for me and every game after that
before every game I listen to lose
yourself by him and if I hear the song
right now I heard it on the radio I have
to turn it off because I wrote no
kidding that that's how that's how much
respect I have for that whole situation
and how that really helped change my
career and it's funny I could hear
Gruden's voice too when you're telling
that story he said you know that guy
you're gonna get the ball four times all
right all right you're gonna take your
big you gonna run for a first down no
matter where we are all right all right
that was that was him I mean I always
have the most respect for him I'm glad
to see he's back in the game to game
dinner Phil needs him his personality I
agree the NFL needs him I agree I agree
and then let's just talk about that
Super Bowl that Super Sunday what was
that like for you in South Florida
Thomas Jones uh the bet was it was
surreal just a real moment yeah it's
your kid you watch the Super Bowl
you watch them heroes playing a Super
Bowl as a kid you know I watch all the
Super Bowls and you know I remember
watching the Redskins I'm from Virginia
so I watched Timmy Smith and you know
even though he can have a great career
you remember the running backs to do
well in the Super Bowl um and you know
Walter Payton obviously was somebody I
looked up to
I had the kangaroo shoes and in the
headband nice I mean the Super Bowl is
the biggest game you could ever play in
and and for me to go to the Super Bowl
with the Chicago Bears was an
unbelievable experience the Chicago
Bears it came and went super fast you
know you wouldn't hit NFC Championship
game against the Saints and next thing
you know you the best feeling in the
world two weeks later in the game
they're pulling the ropes off and you've
lost the worst feeling ever so it was
like this two-week swing that that was
very it was very hard to figure out what
happened and to this day I have not have
not watched the Super Bowl I can't to
this day I can't watch have you been
watching princes half times everyone no
no no no I can't it's losing the Super
Bowl is like the girlfriend that got
away
it really is it's like you you you never
get over
that feeling because you know if you
you're married and you found a bright
person I mean you know that's it's very
slim chance that you're gonna find the
right person and to get to the to the
Super Bowl to have a chance to I have a
chance to win especially I had a good
game on top of it you don't get over so
usually what I do during the playoffs is
you know I'll find something else to do
and I'm in the gym on a Super Bowl
Sunday playing basketball and my mom
I'll call my mom and she'll tell me well
know what happened later on so on I mean
you're saying you haven't just not
watched your own Super Bowl you don't
watch the Super Bowl are you serious yes
watch this you've Thomas Jones you have
not watched a Super Bowl no not since
and what made it worse is with the Jets
we went to the AFC Championship game
right and and we're one more one game
away and got beat by Peyton Manning
again right so um no I haven't you know
that's how connected I was to the game
and and how much football meant to me
and and that's the only thing one of the
only things among the regrets that I
have in my life is not winning Super
Bowl and we'll call each other and text
each other me Brian Urlacher all of you
know around Super Bowl Sunday
somehow Olin Kreutz somehow we'll text
each other and say how we lose a damn
game how do we lose a damn I got to be
honest with you not to but I was talking
about it I believe on the postgame show
that night if you had told me that the
defense the cover two would make Peyton
Manning dump it off all day because he
he always will just always hit the open
receiver that's what he was the sheriff
was known for right with you the Thomas
Jones run for over a hundred yards and
Devin asked her to return the opening
kickoff for a touchdown I've said
Barry's gonna win this football game
yeah I mean I would have put my money on
that too
it just goes to show you that game is up
for grabs man and I it started raining
right before the game so I this is our
game you had you know that's what we did
we know we ran the ball and we play
defense and they just made more plays
than us and we turn the ball over too
much and and we even had it shot at the
end I think that's what makes it worse
sometimes it's best to get blown out
because then it's like well you know we
can have a chance but then you're at the
end of the game you down five you're
driving this is like we
we're gonna be one of those historic
Super Bowl teams that comes back comes
from behind in the fourth quarter
mm-hmm and then you know I'm I look up
in there and I see it's gotta pick six
guys running towards me I'm like no
that's not gonna happen
so yeah it's it's it's devastating man
it's devastating you know the fans on
social media no I stay in contact with
fans on social media and Chicago Bears
fans and Jets fans and the Bears fans
that's the one thing I just did an
interview with with Bears bar room two
days ago and still talk about it and
that was an old seven well let's take a
break in 60 seconds and turn the page to
your acting career okay where I can
pretty much safely say that one day when
you are nominated for an Emmy away baton
Manning will not be in the field as well
okay this you got that go yes he beat me
out for that too brother
because I'd love to again when we come
back in 60 seconds with Thomas we'll
talk to count
Thomas Q Jones you okay yeah we'll talk
about that with the the man who's in
Netflix is Luke Cage as the role of
Comanche Thomas Q Jones back in 60
seconds okay we're back
Thomas Jones now known on the silver
screen big screen what have you as
Thomas Q Jones the actor plays the role
of Comanche in Marvel's Luke Cage with
such a great cast how'd you get in
acting Thomas I've retired in 2012 and I
mean that's a good question III never
had any aspirations of being an actor
I'd spent time in LA I was drafted by
the Cardinals in and I would go to tell
Hollywood come to LA on our off days
sometimes you know just to kind of get
away from everything was going on in
Arizona so I spent time in Hollywood I
wasn't really a big fan of it once I was
traded to Tampa I was back on the East
Coast I didn't come back to LA again and
I was in a relationship for a long time
with with an actress in Hollywood so I
had to be here in the offseason and I
was I hated it I hated LA I hated it
just being here you know so how'd you
get into it well I retired and I had a
production company where I was working
with musicians okay
and
one of my friends has a time convinced
me to start producing a TV show at a at
a you know a film production company TV
production company to it so I said okay
and the show was already there it was
already set up so all I did was just
come in and help reduce it and I took a
little role in it and and I kind of
liked it and the publicist was like hey
you know you have some natural ability
we're gonna get you an agent we're gonna
get you in Hollywood and I'm like no I
hate Hollywood I can do it here but I
don't want to move to LA you know plus
usually during the season I'm away from
my father I'm away from my house my
house is in Miami so I'd never really
consistently been been at my house I was
there in the offseason for a couple of
months and then I'm back in New York you
just want to live life like a purse to
be in my house training camp no no yeah
sure come on bed before a year of
straight yeah so I ended up end up going
to New York with her she introduced me
to an agent the agent would send me on
auditions and be honest I I wouldn't I
would go I wouldn't go I'd act I gotta
get the email I'm sorry I just didn't
want to go so I ended up going on my
first audition for shameless never saw
the show never didn't know William HMAC
didn't know any of these people were
booked it fortunately for me out there
wasn't any lines because I didn't know
what I was doing but you know it was a
great credit and and I ended up doing
that and then the next big thing that I
booked was a show called being Mary Jane
opt to play Gabrielle Union's love
interest and that's when I said um okay
this is pretty sure all I had to go to
Atlanta the next week on Thursday and
and I was so green and I had no classes
that I looked at the script I didn't
know if there was a love scene I didn't
I didn't figure that out figure that out
I just saw in my lines my I only had six
lines so I said okay I'll go up here
I'll say these six lines and it'll be
cool and I'll go back but when I when I
got to set when I went into wardrobe you
know from my outfit they they came in
the room and they were like okay well
here's here's what you're wearing and it
was like this little like tea bag
looking thing
I mean I literally was like okay you
know you know he's like something I'll
have something real will happen to you
and you like oh something real is about
to have yeah you know like you get a
feeling in your chest your stomach yeah
so I got this like weird feeling like
hold on a second like it was like this
little like brown teabag I know this
since the Super Bowl yeah so I'm like
whoa what is this for and like well it's
you know it's a shock and I'm like so
what I do it in guys like he looked at
the other person like how do I tell him
he doesn't have like any other clothes
and I'm like kind of having like nervous
breakdown a little bit cuz I'm like whoa
boy wait is not what I signed up for you
know and so he told me what to do with
it and so heat it out and I went back to
my trailer and I called my friend DeSean
in New York and I said bro I don't know
what I got myself into and he's like
what do you mean I don't have any
clothes he's like what I'm like I don't
have any clothes and he's like what did
they give you an I took a picture sent
it to him he's dying laughs and I'm like
it's not funny
people do a rehearsal Regina King was
the director Regina King was a director
right he's yeah she is and so she goes
well Gabby wants to do a rehearsal so
I'm like okay so I don't know what they
were hurt I don't know we did rough life
like what what did I get myself into so
we do the rehearsal the blocking which I
had no idea what that meant and I didn't
know if we're gonna rehearse the loves I
don't know what wears how green I was
but I couldn't no yeah so you know we
did the blocking you're gonna be here
when you say this line you'll be able to
say this line bah bah blah whatever so I
go back to my trailer and I know wasn't
supposed to do this but I was so like
just that I had like the assistant I'm
like listen can you take me to the store
real quick
they took me to the store and I had like
a shop I got to get a shot
that's how like uncomfortable I was my
was out of alcohol yes okay then I'm
being honest because I was I was then I
come because it hit me like you're
really acting man like you know like
this isn't just like some game you play
no how did it go on you
if it's safe for work to do it went I
mean listen though I had six lines hmm
fortunately and and they weren't really
it wasn't really a lot of dialogue so
and then the character was something
that I was comfortable enough to with
because was because I could just act
like what would I do in this situation
right right it wasn't like this layered
complex character and then the love
scenes were you know mean obviously
everything's super professional
Gabrielle's one the best in the business
and she was very you know patient and
understood what's going on but I was
like okay I know how to do this part so
you know all right okay let me make sure
at least this part I can do the other
part I might look stupid but this part I
can't look stupid and any Kanak and it
came out great and after I did that
episode I had two more episodes and that
was like what are they called scared
straight you know yeah that scared me
into like get you need to get some
acting classes before you make a fool
out of yourself mhm and ruin your whole
leg your whole name well you needed a
drink
I now need a smoke okay
so in a couple minutes that we have left
here I mean you booked Luke Cage this
thing is blowing yes you up yeah where
does your your career stand now I mean I
imagine I'm producing writing I sold a
film that I starred in an executive
produced called a violent man I play a
mixed martial arts fighter I sold it to
Sony it'll be in theaters October 11th
I'm in pre-production on another film I
just had a guest star role in the Marlon
Wayans show last night Orion BC
fantastic oh I was in a guest star role
on Hawaii five-o a couple months ago
having a couple other films and
pre-production this but the the Marvel's
Luke Cage show right now is it's
incredible I mean I've I really had a
chance I was on season one I had one
episode and ko ko ko' ko ko ko'
is the Jon Gruden of Hollywood to me
sure he's the one that gave me the
chance to believe the mean and really
show my ability I was after that whole
fiasco would be a Mary Jane I moved to
LA I got into three active studios I was
in I was in class class six hours a week
frans Turner shoutout to France Turner
one of them he literally is one of the
most important people my life my acting
coach which I didn't know I needed to
become an actor because I mean
to pull back all these layers on who I
was as a football player hmm and I ended
up doing a self tape sending it in for
this role they loved me they brought me
and I did an audition in front of ABC
disney they loved me to get me one
episode jail like what i did the first
season and said you know what I'm gonna
write you in for seven episodes and I'm
giving you this incredible arc of a
character because I believe in your
ability and I took the ball literally
and ran with it so I'm so happy for you
thank you and you know cuz it's it's so
difficult to transition I mean I i sat
there at my the first rookie symposium I
covered and heard the number of how long
the average NFL career laughs yeah and
just looking around the room saying a
lot of these 21 22 23 year old men are
gonna have to figure out what to do next
at age 26 27 you played for 12 years
which is an incredibly long career yeah
and it's so difficult to transition and
be successful and keep your head on
straight it is it is B it's like when
your career is over you just kind of
spit out it's kinda giving this tornado
for however long you play this crazy
world and then when it's over like okay
there you go boom they drop you off
wherever you land and now when you have
to pick yourself up and that's why I
changed my will added my middle initial
to my actor's name because you know
people I think people are trained to to
think one dimensionally and they'd like
to compartmentalize people especially
athletes they think we can't do anything
else but run jump catch a football
whatever which is so far from the truth
the majority of athletes are some of the
smartest people you have to be and you
know I'm certainly in football I mean
not in PlayBook oh yeah you know it's I
mean I think they see what we do
physically and they think it's just this
brutal you know Neanderthal just like no
you have to be super smart you have to
be a very intuitive instinctive you know
I mean that's why you make it to that
level and play 12 years to play 12 years
a long time because they're constant
trying to get you out the console trying
to not pay you think honestly trying to
bring someone else in to take your job
so I added the cue because I wanted to
make sure that I separated Thomas Jones
the 10,000 yard
Pro Bowl whatever football player from
the actor because I'm a real actor I'm
not just the guy that's just saying let
me just see if I can get in a TV show
and no I really love
acting I love the craft it's helping me
figure out who I am because football put
you in this box because you can only
work within a small area and you can't
really create you can't really be a
human and it takes a lot of the humanity
away from you the way you have to be I'm
a totally different person when I played
when I played I was very intense very
aggressive and and I enjoyed the
violence of the game you know and then
because I started off so bad I had this
chip on my shoulder and and I carry that
throughout my career which i think is
why I was able to do so well towards the
end because I always felt like I had to
prove myself and and that makes you that
kind of person sometimes off the field
and acting helped me really become open
and vulnerable and be okay with showing
me being a human being and that's that's
I think those are the best actors the
ones that show the most humanity I think
that's why people can connect to their
characters and that's what I was able to
do with these Comanche character well
Thomas Q Jones Thomas Quinn Jones right
Thomas Queen Jones the first Thomas
Quinn Jones the first you have come a
long way from the Gabrielle Union sock
sir I'll tell you that
okay great to see you Thomas it's been
too long let's let's let's chat again
soon you welcome here any time from
whatever the heck you got
congratulations to you too man it's been
great I've been following you ever since
it's ESPN I still have a lot of the
tapes from when I played where you were
you know only is be calling for Virginia
Highland yes means do yes I'm sure
oh yeah so to see you doing your thing
now man I'm happy for you right back at
you
Thomas Jones right here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience